and rich edson is live in west palm
beach florida for
us this morning on that hey rich
hey good morning sandra and you know
democrats control the house they
easily pass this bill that would raise
those checks to two thousand dollars
republicans control the senate and the
issue has gotten a little complicated
over there
that's pushed the president to uh repeat
number of times on twitter
that he wants those checks increase and
he wants them done now this is what he
tweeted earlier
quote unless republicans have a death
wish and it is also the right thing to
do they must approve the two thousand
dollar payments asap
six hundred dollars is not enough also
get rid of section two thirty
don't let big tech steal our country
instead of voting on the bill the house
just passed one that only increases
those payments
to two thousand dollars senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell has initiated a
process for a vote
that also includes president trump's
other demands the repeal of a
controversial law that gives tech
companies legal protections
and the creation of an election fraud
commission
president highlighted three additional
issues of national significance which
he would like to see congress tackle
together
this week the senate will begin a
process to bring these three priorities
into focus leader mcconnell holds the
key
to unlocking this dilemma the solution
is a simple one put both bills up
for a simple up or down vote and then
let the chips fall where they may
now democrats say by combining all of
these issues in the senate majority
leader mcconnell is simply just trying
to kill any effort
to increase those payments from six
hundred dollars to two thousand dollars
that would add nearly a half trillion
dollars to the cost of all of this and a
number of republicans say
that is just too much back to you sandra
okay richettson live from florida for us
thank you
more on this now john busse associate
editor of the wall street journal
and a fox news contributor john good
morning to you great to see you so
what happens next well i think that
mcconnell in trying to link these three
uh elements together
is really trying to push this vote on
the additional stimulus down the road to
the point where more republicans are
going to think about this more
republicans are going to think whether
or not they
uh want to break with the president on
it and will side with mcconnell's view
which uh apparently is that the extra
you know several hundred billion dollars
that this would cost is too much
uh and it's not targeted you know at the
at the right people who
need the money most very interesting
perspective on that here's the wall
street journal headline mcconnell at the
bridge
the senate leader tries to minimize the
harm from a vengeful trump
the editorial board goes on to say this
we'll see how this plays out in georgia
but the fault here isn't mitch
mcconnell's
the political damage to the gop comes
from donald trump who's lashing out at
all
the sundry and def at all and sundry in
defeat no matter if it also helps
to elect a democratic senate john
tie those two together newt gingrich did
that at the top of the nine o'clock hour
this morning the impact of the
ongoing battle over this two thousand
dollar payment to the american people
and the senate races in georgia watch
yeah so sorry just a second i really am
very worried
that if he plays a clever parliamentary
game it may look good inside the senate
but it could cost us two senate seats
and control the senate
so i would beg him to bring up the two
thousand dollar payment
as a freestanding independent vote uh
and i'll have people like
senator lefler and senator perdue able
to come back and vote for it
take it off the table as an issue sorry
to cut you off there
john so will he do that well uh he
really doesn't want you uh and the you
know the issue is whether or not the
senate
and the country has the money you know
for uh this
a particular you know program this
expansion of the program
um our editorial was pretty strong on
this issue i'm on the new side
of the of the journal not the editorial
page um
but the editorial page was saying that
look this is you know trump trying to
punish
republicans for not supporting his what
the uh
the editorial page calls his fantasies
about the overturning the election
uh and i think that you know mcconnell
is you know seeing that as well at a
certain point he's going to have to
break with the president
if the republicans are going to stick by
policies that they believe
are appropriate um greg
our economics reporter at the journal
you know points out that
this will cost hundreds of billions of
dollars more uh
that uh one study found that something
on the order of 80
or more of the money that was sent out
in stimulus checks before
were either saved or used to pay down
debt not to stimulate additional demand
which would create more jobs
and so one would expect the same thing
to happen this time around
look the president also has a history of
spending other people's money
and going into bankruptcy and various of
his properties
mcconnell doesn't want him spending the
you know the
the taxpayers money in this last kind of
dash for uh a expanded program that he
did not support initially he supported
the 600
and the election in georgia is going to
be complicated by this because these
were two senators who did support
the the 600 program and are now suddenly
you know changing their view because the
president has changed his view and they
need his support
so it messes up the georgia election no
one is more
sensitive to control of the senate than
mitch mcconnell
he doesn't want to lose his job as head
of the the senate the senate leader
uh but i think he's drawing a line here
john i've got to leave it there i just
want to get this bit of news in real
quickly senator josh hawley
the republican just said in a statement
and this is obviously big news because
he's the first
in the senate to do so says that he will
object to the certification
of president-elect joe biden's electoral
college victory during the joint session
of congress
january 6. he's alleging that some
states failed to follow their election
laws and that big tech interfered on
behalf of biden
he's the first senator to say that he'll
object joining obviously a group of
house republicans
to say so as well all these senators are
going to have to go on the record
as to what exactly they're going to do
real quick response to that i got
five seconds well good luck with that
he's a big supporter of the president i
think this is
effort to support the president's view
of this but a lot of other senators
uh republican governors republicans
secretaries of state supreme court other
other uh lawmakers have you know biden
won the election
uh and uh and the president's efforts to
turn it uh
overturned it or simply not going to
advance got it that is breaking news and
we'll have more on that coming up john
always good to see you thank you